[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit gundula
gause und bettina schausten guten abend
es ist eine woche der turbo diplomatie
um russland zum einlenken zu bewegen die
drohkulisse an der grenze zur ukraine
lässt den amerikanischen außenminister
von einer krise mit globalen folgen
warnen anthony blinken bemühte sich
heute in berlin um den schulterschluss
mit den europäern bevor er morgen in
genf seinen russischen amtskollegen
lawrow treffen wird was kann dabei
herauskommen
dazu gleich mehr in einem interview dass
wir mit blinken führen konnten über
seine diplomatische mission berichtet
zunächst andreas kienast
es bringt an diesem morgen jeder der
westlichen diplomaten ein problem mit
nach berlin das er gestern abend noch
nicht hatte das problem des us
außenministers heißt heute joe biden der
us-präsident hat letzte nacht für
verwirrung gesorgt weil er so klang als
hätte nur ein großer angriff russlands
große konsequenzen als sei ein kleiner
angriff vielleicht hinnehmbar
es ist eine sache wenn es sich um ein
geringfügiges eindringen russlands in
die ukraine handelt aber wenn die russen
tatsächlich alles tun wozu sie in der
lage sind dann wird das für russland
eine katastrophe
als minister blinken im auswärtigen amt
ankommt wird es noch acht stunden dauern
bis sein präsident sich persönlich
korrigiert beiden formulierung hat die
verbündeten geschockt und die botschaft
die von berlin aus gehen soll schon vor
dem senden geschwächt die usa
deutschland frankreich und
großbritannien seite an seite für die
souveränität der ukraine gegen jedes
eindringen geringfügig oder nicht
zum beispiel die behauptung die
lieferung von verteidigungswaffen an die
ukraine durch die usa durch europäische
länder oder die nato könnte ein grund
für russlands aktionen sein
das stellt die welt auf den kopf
auch die deutsche außenministerin hat
ein problem berbalk muss neben blinken
der staatsanwaltschaft kooperation zu
sagen die wegen bonuszahlungen im grünen
bundesvorstand ermittelt erst die zweite
journalisten frage betrifft nord stream
zwei werburg kann auf die neue tonlage
von bundeskanzler stolz verweisen
dass wenn es zu einer weiteren
eskalation kommen sollte alle maßnahmen
auf dem tisch liegen und daran hat sich
logischerweise in den letzten 24 stunden
nichts verändert dass deutschland vor 48
stunden nord stream 2 auf den tisch
gelegt hat ist eine der wichtigsten
erkenntnisse die blinkend mitnimmt aus
berlin das problem dass bundeskanzler
scholz jetzt hat heißt spd ein teil
seiner partei lehnt sanktionen gegen
russland ab und gegen nord stream 2 erst
recht am nachmittag beim virtuellen
neujahrsempfang des ost ausschusses der
deutschen wirtschaft sind das einzige
land das eine der mächtigsten spd frauen
kritisiert die usa
hat sich immer hinter den bau der
ostseepipeline gestellt und ich bin sehr
dankbar dass auch der ost ausschuss der
deutschen wirtschaft immer klar position
bezogen hat insbesondere auch dann wenn
aus den usa versucht wurde das projekt
mit sanktionen und sanktionsdrohungen zu
stoppen die usa legen heute neue
luftbildaufnahmen vor die russische
truppen 13 kilometer vor der
ukrainischen grenze zeigen sollen
außenminister blinken hat in berlin
unterstützung gefunden für sein gespräch
morgen mittler drauf aber auch neue
probleme
nach den gesprächen in berlin und vor
dem treffen mit seinem russischen
amtskollegen morgen in genf begrüße ich
jetzt den amerikanischen außenminister
blinken secretary
guten abend schön dass ich zuallererst
wie groß schätzen sie die gefahr eines
russischen einmarsch in die ukraine
heute abend ein
reales risiko und ist ein hohes risiko
russland hatte an der grenze zur ukraine
signifikante zahlen und soldaten
zusammengezogen 100000 soldaten und
nicht nur in der ukraine sondern
unlängst auch soldaten nach belarus
geschickt worden es ist also ein echtes
risiko und das ist nicht nur die
tatsache dass dort trocken
zusammengezogen worden sind sondern auch
unglücklicherweise weil russland das
2014 schon einmal gemacht hat als die
tem annektiert wurde und als die kräfte
in den osten der ukraine entsandt worden
sind das heißt wir müssen uns dort im
augenblick sehr stark darauf
konzentrieren und gleichzeitig ist es
ehrlicherweise so dass nur präsident
putin wirklich sagen kann was man vorhat
sie treffen nun seinen außenminister
sergei lavrov morgen in genf auf
neutralem boden was ist ihre
hauptbotschaft
anleihen haupt dass wir und wenn ich
hier sage dann meine ich nicht nur die
vereinigten staaten sondern auch europa
und die nato und die eu die g7-länder
alle die
sehr sehr eng miteinander koordiniert
und kommuniziert haben dass wir alle
eigentlich zwei verschiedene sind erst
aus diese wege heraus sehen und
vorschlagen die von ost mancher herbes
wird wissen die eine den weg für der
diplomatie und dialog wo wir gemeinsam
versuchen die bedenken anzusprechen die
wir alle teilen über die sicherheit in
europa und der andere weg wenn russland
den wählen sollte besteht in einer
konfrontation mit entsprechenden
konsequenzen massiven konsequenzen für
russland hinsichtlich der reaktionen
unserer länder und ich werde den
außenministern la france sehen aber ich
war auch in kiew jetzt war ich in berlin
wo ich auch nicht nur mit unseren
deutschen partnern mich zusammen setzen
konnte sondern auch mit den anderen
partner in frankreich und großbritannien
konsequenzen sagen sie präsident biden
hat gestern zunächst gesagt dass es bei
einem kleineren eindringen russland in
die ukraine nur zu begrenzten reaktionen
der nato käme das jetzt korrigiert aber
zur klarstellung
ist die amerikanische rote linie
es ist nicht so sehr eine frage einer
über konsequenzen reden dann sind das
übrigens nicht nur die vereinigten
staaten die diese ankündigen wir haben
entsprechende ankündigungen auch von den
g7 das sind also die führenden
demokratischen wirtschaftsräume der welt
aber auch der eu und der nato dass das
neben droht nämlich massive konsequenzen
falls russland gegen ukraine vorgeht und
wenn ein russischer soldat über die
grenze in die ukraine eindringt gefahr
und dann haben wir es mit einem
wirkliche profunden problemen zu tun
denn das ist ein ganz klarer angriff auf
die ukraine ob es sich nun um einen oder
um 1000 soldaten handelt was der
präsident jedoch gestern meinte war dass
er
sich auf szenarien bezogen hat die eben
nicht so weitgehend dass russische
kräfte in die ukraine einmarschierenden
das könnte sehr ähnliche auswirkungen
haben wie russland da vorgehen wollen
könnte wie beispielsweise wenn es darum
geht einen staatsstreich herbeizuführen
der die regierung beiseite legte aber
mithilfe hybrider methoden oder mit
anderen sondereinsätzen die nicht so
einfach erkennbar sind aber was wir in
enger koordination schon seit vielen
wochen bearbeiten besteht darin dass wir
sicherstellen wollen dass für alle diese
szenarien für alle diese aktivitäten
dann auch russland eben im falle einer
aggression gegen die ukraine dass wir
alle gemeinsam die feindlichen staaten
und europa wir koordiniert sind und dass
wir einen plan haben wie bei effektiv
mit diesen szenarien also für alle diese
szenarien höre ich daraus werden sela
wurf in irgendeiner form
sicherheitsgarantien geben versprechen
geben und russland damit entgegenkommen
wir haben bereits ein entgegenkommen
gezeigt nicht nur in den vergangenen
wochen sondern schon über viele jahre
hinweg und zwar durchgängig wir haben
immer wieder betont dass wir russland
gegenüber offen sind und mit russland
zusammenarbeiten wollen den russen und
konzentriert seine energie und seine
ressourcen seien talente nicht mal das
ist eine großartige nation und wir
müssen dann vielen bereichen
zusammenarbeiten es geht hier nur als
unsere bürger ob wir über den
klimawandel sprechen über kurven die
auswirkungen neuer technologien in all
diesen bereichen würden wir wirklich
gerne mit russland zusammenarbeiten und
über viele jahre hinweg hat die nato die
hand ausgestreckt um eben transparent
und positive beziehungen zu knüpfen
unglücklicherweise sind wir immer wieder
zurückgewiesen worden und tatsächlich
ist es so dass das in den vergangenen
jahren so war das nicht die nato das
problem war denn wir sind ein
verteidigungsbündnis
das ist transparent ist und freiwillig
in der mitglied struktur sondern dass
russland eben die ukraine angegriffen
hat georgien angerissen hat dass es dort
der militärische kräfte in moldau gibt
und russland hat deswegen eine große
herausforderung für die europäische
sicherheit dargestellt wir würden gerne
eine stabile und feuer sagt beyrer
beziehungen mit russland entwickeln und
präsident biden hat das auch präsident
mutigen direkt mitgeteilt und es gibt
bereiche wo wir zusammenarbeiten können
aber es hängt auch sehr davon ab was
russland tut oder lässt was erwarten sie
in diesem prozess nun von den europäern
was von deutschland konkret gefragt
sollte auch deutschland waffen liefern
an die ukraine
jedes land trifft die eigenen
entscheidungen darüber wie
partner ländern wie der ukraine hilfe
angeboten wird im falle der vereinigten
staaten haben wir defensives
militärmaterial schon seit jahren an die
ukraine geliefert und werden das auch
weiterhin tun
aber es zeigt auch noch einmal sehr
deutlich welche ja fast schon ironie in
dieser situation liegt
denken sie mal darüber nach die
aktivitäten russlands waren es die im
laufe der jahre eigentlich dazu geführt
haben was putin eigentlich immer
vermeiden wollte bevor russland die krim
annektiert hat und im jahr 2014 in die
ost ukraine einmarschiert ist war die
zustimmung zur nato in der ukraine bei
25% jetzt liegt sie bei 60 prozent die
nato hat ihre ostgrenzen erst als
ergebnis der russischen aggression
verstärkt und bei der frage des defensiv
materials das an die ukraine geliefert
wird das ist erst nach 2014 geschehen
als reaktion und antwort auf die
russische aggression damit die ukraine
sich verteidigen kann die verschiedenen
länder helfen der ukraine auf
verschiedene arten und weisen sie
akzeptieren aber dass deutschland auf
seine geschichte verweist und keine
waffen liefert
ich sage es noch einmal das sind
souveräne entscheidungen die unsere
verbündeten und partner selber treffen
wie sie unterstützung anbieten wollen
aber was ganz klar ist ist folgendes wir
wie groß ist sind
tatsächlich so eng wie nur möglich hat
bei der koordination und bei der
zusammenarbeit wenn es um die
herausforderung von bussen gegenüber der
ukraine gehe und ich kann mich in meiner
eigenen lebenserfahrung nicht daran
erinnern dass wir in engen
konsultationen zu größeren oder
wichtigen kunden gehabt hätten was
unsere gemeinsame sicherheit man geht in
diesem punkt könnten wir nicht enger
zusammenarbeiten sie haben gerade mit
bundeskanzler scholz gesprochen der die
pipeline nord stream 2 als ein
privatwirtschaftliches projekt
bezeichnet hat haben sie ihm das
ausgeredet
depression nicht einmal mir eine ehre
und auch an der freude zeit mit dem
kanzler verbringen dürfen wir haben sehr
produktive und sehr durchdachte
gespräche zu ganz vielen verschiedenen
themen gehabt
haben uns über vieles ausgetauscht aber
was wir auch wissen ist dass jen ist um
die herausforderungen unserer zeit geht
wie wird damit immer gehen nämlich in
einer partnerschaft in einem bündnis und
in den multilateralen organisationen
dann sind deutschland und die usa
wirklich voll miteinander in der
gleichen richtung ausgerichtet und in
der in den vereinigten staaten wissen
wir dass wir keinen besseren partner als
deutschland haben können und bei der
noch stören diese weisheit nein da sind
unsere an sichern ansichten schon seit
langem bekannt und wir sind gegen bei
denen die inbetriebnahme dieser pipeline
aber ich habe den kanzler auch erst zum
unlängst zwei paar tagen erst gehört
dass im falle einer russischen
aggression entgegen die ukraine es
schwerwiegende kosten zu tragen gebe und
dass alles auf dem tisch ist
und natürlich haben die feindlichen
staaten und deutschland im letzten
sommer als kanzlerin merkel im amt war
sich darauf geeinigt welche gemeinsame
strategien wir für die energiesicherheit
und auch die eine die sicherheit der
ukraine verfolgen aber wir haben uns
auch verpflichtet das energie
lieferungen von russland nicht als waffe
verwendet werden sollen und dürfen und
ich weiß dass der kanzler auch diese
verpflichtung noch einmal bekräftigt hat
wo stehen wir morgen abend nach ihrem
gespräch mit la wolf im besten fall was
kann
ich erwarte jetzt erst einmal keinen
großen durchbrüche aber wir haben in der
jüngeren vergangenheit
viele intensive gespräche gehabt mit
russland in unserem strittiges
stabilitäts dialog zwischen den usa und
russland direkt dann im
nato-russland-rat
und dann auch beispielsweise im rahmen
der oecd schätzt jetzt haben wir die
gelegenheit gehabt darüber nachzudenken
was wir dort gehört haben und ich glaube
auch dass große stehtische team hat eine
gelegenheit gehabt sich mit präsident
putin zu beraten wir haben die
gelegenheit gehabt uns zu behalten auch
unter den verbündeten und partnern und
das ist jetzt ein wichtiger augenblick
um erst einmal eine bestandsaufnahme
außenminister lavrov zu erheben um zu
sehen welche schlüsse russland aus
diesen diplomatischen gesprächen zieht
und das wird dann auch russland ganz
klar aufzeigen was unsere positionen
sind und die position unserer
verbündeten und partner denn wir
sprechen mit einer stimme und um auch
herauszufinden ob wir weiterhin den
diplomatischen pfad zur lösung dieser
krise bestreiten können das ist die
frage und wir werden morgen hoffentlich
dann mehr darüber wissen und wir werden
auch herausfinden ob großen und wirklich
ein interesse daran hat diese
differenzen durch einen dialog und
diplomatisch zu lösen oder nicht in
jedem falle sind wir bereit und wir sind
gemeinsam unterliegt der amerikanische
haus minister im zdf heute journal
herzlichen dank dankeschön ist das
sekretärin nach berlin
vielen dank
das gespräch haben wir am abend
aufgezeichnet und in den nachrichten
schauen wir nun zunächst auf die
kuranlage gundula gause nach
einschätzung von
bundesgesundheitsminister
lauterbach wird ist mitte februar
wahrscheinlich täglich mehrere
hunderttausend corona infektionen geben
im zdf sprach zudem von einer hohen
dunkelziffer und warnte vor neuen
belastungen für die krankenhäuser das rk
ii registrierte aktuell
1536 neue fälle innerhalb eines tages
52.000 119 mehr als vor einer woche
234 todesfälle kamen hinzu die sieben
tage incidents stieg weiter auf 600
38,8
österreich führt als erstes eu-land ab
februar eine allgemeine impfpflicht
gegen das corona virus ein das parlament
hat ein entsprechendes gesetz
verabschiedet dass kontrollen ab mitte
märz und geldstrafen für impfverweigerer
vorsieht zugleich sind finanzielle
anreize für impfungen geplant geimpfte
können gutscheine im wert von 500 euro
gewinnen gemeinden sollen für hohe
impfquoten zusätzliche finanzhilfen
erhalten die fdp fraktion hat klage beim
bundesverfassungsgericht gegen die neuen
core ohne regeln im bundestag
eingereicht die neue zweig plus regel im
bundestag müsse sofort aufgehoben werden
damit jeder abgeordnete unabhängig von
seinem impfstatus
diskriminierungsfrei seine aufgaben im
parlament wahrnehmen können
israel und deutschland haben die annahme
einer gemeinsamen resolution gegen die
leugnung des holocaust durch die
generalversammlung der vereinten
nationen begrüßt aus ministerin berbalk
und ihr israelischer amtskollege la pete
erklärten zum achtzigsten jahrestag der
wannseekonferenz sie seien sehr besorgt
über die dramatische zunahme von
leugnung und verfälschung des holocaust
bei der wannseekonferenz heute vor 80
jahren beschlossen vertreter von ns
führung und verwaltung
die systematische ermordung der juden in
europa
fünf tage nach dem vulkanausbruch vor
tonga haben erste hilfsflüge den
inselstaat im pazifik erreicht
militärmaschinen aus australien und
neuseeland haben
trinkwasseraufbereitungsanlagen
kommunikationsausrüstung und andere
versorgungsgüter auf die insel gebracht
ohne kontakt zu den einwohnern um zu
verhindern dass das corona virus nach
tonga eingeschleppt wird morgen wird
zudem ein containerschiff mit 250.000
litern trinkwasser erwartet geschickt
von neuseeland
es ist ein vernichtendes urteil das das
münchner missbrauchs gutachten der
katholischen diözese münchen und
freising ausstellt
1893 seiten system versagen und schuld
die würdenträger in den letzten
jahrzehnten aus sich luden hinweise auf
fast 500 opfer sexualisierter gewalt und
ein system das die täter schützt und
nicht die opfer kardinal marx kardinal
wetter es sind die prominentesten namen
auch kardinal ratzinger der spätere
papst benedikt muss sich vertuschung
vorwerfen lassen das gutachten das heute
veröffentlicht wurde ist ein protokoll
der kaltherzigkeit barbara lueg
berichtet
es ist die geschichte eines
beispiellosen versagen es geht um schuld
versäumnisse um verrat darum dass kirche
schon lange verloren hat was sie im kern
sein soll
richard krieg selbst missbrauchsopfer
und im betroffenen beirat des erzbistums
münchen hat dieser tag ins mark
getroffen
im blick sollte der mensch stehen der
mensch als person und
das ist jahrzehntelang nicht der fall
gewesen sondern ist zwar die macht ja
dieser herren und die stehen im fokus
der juristen heute kardinal wetter
kardinal marx und der emeritierte papst
und frühere münchner erzbischof joseph
ratzinger
sie schützten ihre institution anstatt
der opfer in insgesamt vier fällen sind
wir zu der einschätzung gelangt dass dem
damaligen erzbischof kardinal ratzinger
in fällen sexuellen missbrauchs ein
fehlverhalten vorzuwerfen ist sein fall
steht im zentrum priester peter h werden
besonders viele missbrauchs taten
zugeschrieben zunächst als kaplan in
essen in den 70ern als es passiert ist
wilfried fesselmann elf jahre messdiener
heute spricht er über das grauen dann
hat er mir irgendwas alkoholisches zu
trinken gegeben und ja dann hat er sich
ausgezogen ich musste mich ausziehen ja
und am ende habe muss ich ihnen dann
halt oral befriedigen doch statt den
pädophilen priester zu entlasten wird er
nach münchen versetzt joseph ratzinger
ist dort zu der zeit erzbischof peter h
missbraucht weiter ratzinger erklärt nun
er sei in der entscheidenden sitzung und
peter h nicht dabei gewesen
ich formuliere zurückhaltend wir
erhalten die angabe des papstes benedikt
er sei in dieser sitzung nicht anwesend
gewesen
als wenig glaubwürdig eine bilanz des
schreckens nennen die juristen ihre
erkenntnisse heute von historischer
zäsur ist wird dieses gutachten ein
katapult veränderung seien das problem
ist die mangelnde rezeption auf der
ebene von papst und bischöfen ich gehe
davon aus dass viele katholikinnen und
katholiken die ihren glauben in der
moderne leben wollen anders denken
tatsächlich jetzt sich stärker
verselbstständigen am ende tritt
kardinal marx noch vor die kamera mit
einem versprechen zur aufarbeitung und
zum weiteren weg gehört die orientierung
an den opfern des missbrauchs die
aufarbeitung von falschen
machtstrukturen und haltungen und dann
tritt der erzbischof ab wie lange er
sein amt noch innehat wer weiß
experte jürgen erbacher mit namen jürgen
das gutachten bestätigt macht die
abgründe fast noch tiefer die man aber
im grunde ja auch schon kennt was sind
jetzt die konsequenzen wann geht es
sozusagen wirklich auch an die
strukturen gut als erste konsequenz
müssten jetzt diejenigen denen hier
fehlverhalten nachgewiesen wird die
verantwortung übernehmen bis hin
vielleicht auch zum rücktritt das
lindert zwar nicht das leid der
betroffenen aber es wäre ein klares
signal dass ihr schicksal ernst genommen
wird und es geht dann ganz klar darum
die systemischen ursachen die missbrauch
und vertuschung begünstigt haben
anzugehen und abzustellen das heißt
reformen müssen her das ist das
stichwort gewaltenteilung macht
kontrolle es geht aber auch um reformen
im bereich der theologie zum beispiel
bei der sexualmoral
kardinal marx hat heute in dem kurzen
statement ja gesagt für ihn gehört
aufarbeitung ganz klar mit reform der
kirche zusammen aber daran hapert es
natürlich und wissen nicht für solche
reformen auch ein signal jetzt aus dem
vatikan kommt ja ganz klar bräuchte es
klare signale rückendeckung aus dem
vatikan für reformen in der ganzen welt
wird in den lokalen kirchen über genau
die reformen diskutiert über die auch
hier in deutschland diskutiert wird der
papst agiert allerdings zögerlich er
lässt sich aus meiner sicht von einer
kleinen aber lauten konservativen gruppe
sehr beeindruckend und dann entsteht der
eindruck als würde nichts passieren
im vatikan hat man heute übrigens gesagt
man wird das gutachten sehr genau
studieren und auch der sekretär von
benedikt hat gesagt wir werden es uns
anschauen
die betroffenen warten jetzt natürlich
auf eine an dort von ihm würde er
schweigen wäre das genau die fortsetzung
dessen was die kirche über jahrzehnte
gemacht hat dieses verhalten das heißt
jetzt ist ein signal von benedikt auch
gefordert dankeschön jürgen erbacher für
die einschätzung ja und im heute-journal
update vertiefen wir die frage nach den
konsequenzen weiter christopher hermann
spricht mit dem missbrauchsbeauftragten
der bundesregierung hans wilhelm röhrig
der der kirche kalten pragmatismus
vorwirft die betroffenen seien
konsequent nicht wahrgenommen worden
jetzt nochmal nachrichten grüne lack auf
bundeswirtschaftsminister habe auch für
klimaschutz zuständig will mit besuchen
in allen bundesländern den ausbau der
windkraft in deutschland voranbringen in
bayern sind da die sehr strengen
abstandsregeln für windräder thema
ministerpräsident söder sagte
kompromissbereitschaft zu minister
habeck forderte so wörtlich ökologischen
patriotismus ein
mehr anstrengungen beim ausbau des
ökostroms mahnen nicht nur die ampel
parteien an sondern auch behörden und
verbände die energiewende bleibt eine
mammut-aufgabe stefanie berit für
wirtschaft und gesellschaft
ja und wenn die ehrgeizigen ziele
erreicht werden sollen dann müssen vor
allem alle bundesländer ins boot sonst
scheitert der komplette ausbau
erneuerbarer energien
fakt ist von 20 21 wurden fast drei
viertel der neu installierten leistung
durch windkraft von niedersachsen
brandenburg nordrhein-westfalen und
schleswig-holstein gestimmt bayern baden
württemberg und sachsen trugen dagegen
im vergangenen jahr zusammen nur 7,4
prozent zum ausbau der windkraft bei
mehr tempo fordert nun der bundesverband
windenergie insgesamt sei eine
verdreifachung des ausbaus nötig das
zähe genehmigungsverfahren beschleunigt
werden sollen es hinlänglich bekannt
doch auch transportbedingungen für
bauteile müssten verbessert werden so
der verband zudem genügend fachkräfte
für aufbau und inbetriebnahme verfügbar
sein und nicht zuletzt ausreichend
ausgewiesene flächen und zwar in jedem
bundesland doch all das bedarf auch der
akzeptanz vor ort das ist denn wind
männern schon klar denn jedes windrad
hat uns einen gegner und auch der sollte
überzeugt und ins boot geholt werden
eine von vielen herausforderungen vielen
dank stefanie bareth
zum sport tennis profi philipp
kohlschreiber ist als elfter von
ursprünglich zwölf deutschen startern
bei den australian open in melbourne
ausgeschieden
der 38 jährige augsburger unterlag dem
spanier bautista gut glatt in drei
sätzen
die deutschen hoffnungen ruhen damit
komplett auf olympiasieger alexander
zverev die korona geplagte deutsche
handball nationalmannschaft hat ihr
erstes hauptrundenspiel bei der haupt
bei der europameisterschaft verloren 23
29 gegen titelverteidiger spanien 11
positiv getestete spieler fallen aktuell
in bratislava aus trotzdem war die party
zunächst sehr eng viele deutsche
angriffe scheiterten am starken torhüter
spaniens es gibt aber noch chancen auf
das em halbfinale morgen im nächsten
hauptrundenspiel gegen norwegen live im
zdf ab 20 15
ich hatte ein wunderschönes leben hat
hardy krüger oft gesagt und die
geschichte vom kleinen eberhard aus
berlin erzählt der die kindheit in nazi
deutschland hinter sich ließ und nach
hollywood kam ein weltstar auf der
leinwand war er der den deutschen später
die welt erklärte und eine verantwortung
spürte die lehren aus der geschichte aus
seiner geschichte weiter zu geben 93
wurde er bei felix jochens erinnert an
hardy krüger
ein schauspieler muss nicht der sein den
er darstellt hardy krüger vor allem
bekannt als sunnyboy und weltenbummler
wollte als kind gauleiter von moskau
werden auch models klavier stand eine
hitler wüste wenn ich ihn als ich in die
schule kam hitler an der wand und
zwangsläufig war ich der meinung das ist
also halbgott
krügers eltern überzeugte nazis
mit 13 schicken sie ihren sohn auf ein
ns elite-internat
1943 die erste rolle in einem
propagandafilm
es ist der kontakt hinter den kulissen
der krüger damals nach eigenen angaben
leutert dann bin ich dem hand schön kann
wunderbar und mann und einem großen ufa
star begegneten der hat mir gesagt ein
halbgott essen verbrecher gegen
kriegsende muss krüger an die front und
verweigert dort den schießbefehl eines
vorgesetzten dann wollte er mich
erschießen aber dazu sagen nicht mehr
gekommen ich habe ihnen erschoss war
krüger wird zum tode verurteilt aber von
einem ss offizier begnadigt der ihnen
noch an der front braucht zeit seines
lebens verfolgt ihn der
nationalsozialismus selbst der
durchbruch im internationalen
filmgeschäft hat damit zu tun
und dann war das damals dann nicht immer
ein positives schicksal als deutsche
blonde deutsche im amerikanischen film
für offiziere und solche sachen
gebraucht zu werden ich war kam in
amerika als deutscher gar nicht in frage
ich durfte mexikaner spielen nicht es
kommen aber auch andere rollen etwa im
französischen drama sonntage mit siebel
das einen oscar gewinnt oder im großbild
film hatari der den deutschen in den
60ern das fernweh in die wohnzimmer
bringt
[Musik]
krüger schreibt bücher und setzt sich
bis ins hohe alter gegen
rechtsextremismus ein spricht mit
schulklassen über seine erfahrungen im
dritten reich gemeinsam gegen rechte
gewalt ist eines der späten projekte
zusammen mit dieter hallervorden
ich kann diesem lebenswert menschen nur
wünschen mögen ist für ihn hinter
produktion weiter gehen
hardy krüger sunnyboy weltenbummler
filmstar und couragierter mahner wurde
93 jahre alt
heute nacht gegen 1 uhr 15 gibt es mehr
zu hardy krügers leben bei zdf history
eine deutsche legende auch in der zdf
mediathek
und davor also unser heute-journal
update gegen 0.45 mit christoph erwärmen
ja morgen begrüßt sie hier an dieser
stelle christian sievers
[Musik]
schönen guten abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter kaltluft war heute
vorherrschenden deutschland das sieht
man an dieser streuselkuchen artigen
bewölkung die eingeflossen ist von
nordwesten her das reinste aprilwetter
mit graupelschauern schnee und
regenschauern und sogar gewitter im
osten deutschlands ja unter diese
kompakten wolken die legen sich nun
allmählich an die alpen unterwegs in der
nacht weiter schneien aber wie geht es
weiter die kaltluft wird es allmählich
nach osten abgedrängt und sie wird etwas
milder so geht der schnee wieder in
regen über in der nacht also im süden
anhaltende schneefälle weiterhin
ansonsten hier und da schneeschauer im
osten da klar dass auf und generell
nicht nur durch schnee müssen sie mit
glätte rechnen sondern auch durch
überfrierende nässe denn es wird
einigkeit mit zb -5 gerade im osten
deutschlands - 6 an den alpen - 7 im
vogtland einzig frostfrei im nordwesten
mit plus 2 grad morgen tagesverlauf
etwas schneefall noch im südosten
deutschlands und dann wieder regen im
nordwesten und in den mittelgebirgen da
können auch schneeflocken dabei sein
ganz im osten da gibt es viel
sonnenschein das bei höchsten
temperaturen von minus drei grad an den
alpen hier also dauerfrost und plus acht
grad im nordwesten
am samstag kommt viel schnee auf an den
alpen hier stauen sich die wolken
ansonsten wird es trockener nach westen
bei null bis acht grad und auch die
nächsten tage werden deutlich trockener
ausfallen damit ein schöner abend